WE ALL CAME TOGETHER AFTER 9/11.
AND WE SHOULD BE DOING IT AGAIN
NOW.
AMERICA HAS FLATTENED THE CURVE,
THE TASK FORCE SAYS.
THE WORST IS BEHIND US AS LONG
AS WE STAY VIGILANT.
WE’LL BE ABLE TO OPEN UP SLOWLY
AND SAFELY IN PHASES.
IN TO STATES THEY STARTED STOP
DIP THEIR TOWS IN THE WATER.
-- THEIR TOES IN THE WATER.
I SPOKE STOP DR. DEBORAH BIRX.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS MEMORIAL DAY
WHICH IS IN A MOP, WE WILL HAVE
TURNED THE CORNER ON THIS VIRUS
AND WILL BE IN A MUCH, MUCH
BETTER PLAYS?
IS THAT YOUR AFTER HE SUM SHUN.
>> WE BELIEVE THE
HOSPITALIZATION AND THE ICU NEED
AND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SUCCUMBED TO THIS DISEASE
WILL BE DRAMATICALLY DECREASED
ABOUT IT END OF MAY.
NOW WE ARE EXPANDING MORE AND
MORE TESTING.
OUR TESTING WAS PRIORITIZED TO
PEOPLE WHO NEEDED IT FOR
DECISION MAKE.
PEOPLE IN THE HOSPITAL, PEOPLE
WHO WERE SICK, FRONT LINE NURSES
AND FIRST RESPONDERS.
AS WE EXPAND INTO THE GREATER
COMMUNITY WITH MUCH LESS
SYMPTOMS, WE’LL SEE ADDITIONAL
CASE.
BUT WE’VE BELIEVE THEY ARE CASES
CIRCULATING THE COMMUNITY BUTTED
IN THE ASYMPTOMATIC OR MILD
STATE THAT WE WANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
JESSE: HOW COSTLY WAS IT THAT
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT WASN’T
OPEN AND HONEST WITH US IN THE
VERY BEGINNING?
IT MUST HAVE BEEN WHAT, A MONTH?
TWO MONTHS THAT WE LOST BECAUSE
OF THE CHINESE?
>> I THINK THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
EPIDEMIC LOOKED LIKE IN CHINA.
I STILL CAN’T TELL YOU THAT.
ALL WE HAVE BEEN SOLD ARE THE
LIMITED NUMBERS OF CASES AND THE
LIMITED MORTALITY WHICH DOESN’T
MATCH ANY OTHER EXPANSIVE
EPIDEMIC FOR THIS VIRUS.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND WERE THEY
GENETICALLY UNIQUE OR WAS THERE
A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY IN
REPORTING.
JESSE: A VERY DIPLOMATICCANCE
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR HONESTY.
SOME CRITICISM FROM THE MEDIA IS
THE PRESIDENT WAS TOO SLOW IN
CONFRONTING THIS VIRUS.
DO YOU AGREE ON THIS OR NOT?
>> I ARRIVED ON THE SCENE ON THE
2nd OF MARCH.
AND EVERY PIECE OF DATA WE GOT
TO HIM HE LOOKS AT, HE TALKS
THROUGH, AND ASKS QUESTIONS.
HE ASKS QUESTIONS THAT SHOW HE
UNDERSTANDS THE DATA.
PUBLIC HEALTH CHARTS ARE HAVE
MUCH LIKE ECONOMIC CHARTS.
HE HAS A STRONG FOUNDATION IN
DATA IN GENERAL.
SO BEING ABLE TO EXPLAIN TO HIM
WHAT’S HAPPENING IN THE UNITED
STATES COUNTY BY COUNTY, HE
LIKES TO SEE THE DATA.
HE WANTS TO KNOW WHAT’S
HAPPENING AT THE COUNTY LEVEL,
THE COMMUNITY LEVEL, THE STATE
LEVEL AND WHAT’S HAPPENING
GLOBALLY.
HE ASSURED THEM WE ARE LEARNING
FROM OTHERS AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THIS.
WE GET REPORTS DAILY ON HOW
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE HANDLING
OPENING UP AND WE ARE TRACKING
HOW THE STATES ARE DOING AS THEY
OPEN UP THEIR ECONOMICS.
THAT’S INTEGRATING THAT DATA
EVERY DAY FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT.
JESSE: DR. FAUCI SAID WHENEVER
YOU GUYS HAVE GONE TO THE
PRESIDENT WITH A SERIOUS
SCIENTIFIC RECOMMENDATION, HE
HAS ABSORBED THAT AND TAKEN
ACTION.
>> THAT’S ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
JESSE: WE HEARD FROM THE DHS SAY
THURSDAY SUNLIGHT, INCREASED
TEMPERATURE AND HUMIDITY COULD
HAVE AN EFFECT ON KILLING THE
VIRUS IN THE AIR, ON SURFACES.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS SPIT
BALLING AND ASKING QUESTIONS
WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE TO TARGET
THE VIRUS THROUGH A CURE USING
CERTAIN INGREDIENTS OR USING
SUNLIGHT.
YOU DIDN’T BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
WAS PUTTING ANYBODY IN DANGER,
DID YOU?
>> HE GETS NEW INFORMATION AND
HE LIKES TO TALK THAT THROUGH
OUT LOUD AND HAVE THAT DIALOGUE.
THAT’S WHAT DIALOGUE HE WAS
HAVING.
I THINK HE JUST SAW THE
INFORMATION AT THE TIME,
IMMEDIATELY BEFORE THE PRESS
CONFERENCE AND HE WAS STILL
DIGESTING THAT INFORMATION.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALWAYS PUT
HEALTH AND SAFETY FIRST.
I THINK YOU CAN SEE THAT IN THE
WAIVE HE WAS SUPPORTIVE OF
SLOWING THE SPREAD GUIDELINES
KNOWING THE IMPACT THAT WOULD
HAVE ON THE ECONOMY AND KNEW
CLEARLY WHAT IMPACT IT WOULD
HAVE ON THE ECONOMY.
BUT HE REALIZED THE HEALTH AND
SAFE I OF AMERICANS WAS HIS
NUMBER ONE INTEREST AND
RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT’S WHAT
HE DID FIRST AND CONTINUES TO DO
AS WE BEGIN TO OPEN UP.
JESSE: YOU PROBABLY NEVER
IMAGINED YOU WOULD BE DOING THIS
MUCH TELEVISION.
YOU ARE DOING CABLE, AND PRINT,
YOU ARE THERE PAVE SICK CHICAGO
EVERY DAY DOING THESE PRESS
BRIEFINGS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE MEDIA HAS
BEEN FAIR THROUGHOUT’S PANDEMIC.
>> I HAVE DONE MEDIAL ALL OVER
THE WORLD -- I HAVE DONE MEDIA
ALL OVER THE WORLD BECAUSE I
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON PANDEMICS
AROUND THE GLOBE FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS.
I THINK THE MEDIA IS SLICEY AND
DICEY HOW THEY PUT SENTENCES
TOGETHER TO CREATE HEADLINES.
WE KNOW FROM MILLENNIALS AND
OTHER STUDIES THAT SOME PEOPLE
MAY ONLY READ THE HEADLINES.
IF THERE IS NOT A GRAPHIC THEY
ARE NOT GOING THE LOOK ANY
FURTHER THAN THAT.
WE HAVE TO BE RESPONSIBLE ABOUT
OUR HEADLINES.
OFTEN THE REPORTING MAY BE
ACCURATE IN PARAGRAPH 3, 4, AND
5.
BUT I’M NOT SURE HOW MANY PEOPLE
GET TO PARAGRAPH 3, 4, AND 5.
I THINK THE RESPONSIBILITY THE
PRESS HAS IS TO MAKE SURE THE
HEADLINES REFLECT WHAT’S IN
THEIR PIECE.
JESSE: WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR